Katrina: 64遮瑕
Katrina: Shade 64 concealer
Katrina: 是这
Katrina: It's this one.
Nicous: 整合我可没关系我十一衣服来福的关系
Nicous: Honestly, I don't care. My clothes from eleven are from Lafayette.
Katrina: 这是一个颜色
Katrina: This is one color.
Katrina: 他这是哪个色号啊没看懂那个南玻
Katrina: What shade is this? I don't understand that Nanbo.
Katrina: 这是南玻ONE
Katrina: This is Nanbo ONE.
Nicous: 等一下等一下他怎么
Nicous: Wait a minute, wait a minute, how come...
Katrina: 可能也直接买这热销就够了
Katrina: Maybe just buying this bestseller is enough.
Katrina: 反正今天着眼镜录也是路淘宝
Katrina: Anyway, today this glasses makeup is also from Taobao.
Choiszt: 你是一填多尝试检看手机
Choiszt: Did you try to check your phone a lot?
Katrina: 我吗？你是说录这个还是说淘宝
Katrina: Me? are you talking about filming this or talking about the TAOBAO?
Katrina: 一直在玩手机
Katrina: Always playing with the phone.
Katrina: 你一般就看那个
Katrina: Do you usually just look at that?
Katrina: 嗯应该是经典
Katrina: Hmm, probably the classics.
Katrina: 经典基本都买经典
Katrina: I mostly buy the classics.
Katrina: 经典就是卖的好
Katrina: The classics sell well.
Katrina: 也比较适合中国人肤色
Katrina: Also more suitable for Chinese skin tones.
Nicous: 而且最担心的事情还是发生了
Nicous: And the thing I was most worried about still happened.
Choiszt: 什么事情
Choiszt: What happened?
Nicous: 就是他当时录帮我们那个舍友就是怕就是就是他玩手机
Nicous: When he was helping us record, our roommate was worried that he would just play with his phone.
Katrina: 有活动不玩手机
Katrina: There's an event, don't play with the phone.
Katrina: 是因为今天那个
Katrina: It's because today...
Katrina: 他让我们淘宝买那个装饰房子的东西
Katrina: He asked us to buy things to decorate the house on Taobao.
Katrina: 才玩手机
Katrina: That's why he was on the phone.
Katrina: 到底是NO.1还是歌剧魅影的这个
Katrina: Is it NO.1 or Phantom of the Opera?
Katrina: 好像有点不一样
Katrina: Seems a little different.
Katrina: 但是你要把它这样转上去好像又有点
Katrina: But if you twist it up like this, it kind of...
Katrina: 但它热销
Katrina: But it's a bestseller.
Katrina: 那是哪颜色
Katrina: So what color is it?
Katrina: 1234 我靠
Katrina: 1234, whoa
Katrina: 这遮瑕怎么有6颜色
Katrina: How come this concealer has 6 colors?
Katrina: 我都看晕了哈哈
Katrina: I'm getting dizzy from watching this, haha.
Nicous: 好啦好啦就是留个我让他买六个但是他太素了
Nicous: Alright, alright. I asked him to buy six, but he's too simple.
Katrina: 这个他差不多了
Katrina: This one is about right.
Katrina: 靠可多了
Katrina: Wow, that's a lot.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina: 植村秀喷雾
Katrina: Shu Uemura spray.
Nicous: 这个淘宝多少钱
Nicous: How much is this on Taobao?
Katrina: 也没便宜多少
Katrina: Not much cheaper.
Katrina: 嗯就是
Katrina: Yeah, so...
Katrina: 我们一般化了底妆以后
Katrina: Usually after we apply foundation,
Katrina: 他不是那个会黏黏的吗
Katrina: it gets a bit sticky, right?
Katrina: 那就是要么用散粉要么用这个喷雾
Katrina: So we either use loose powder or this spray.
Katrina: 他就不会脱妆
Katrina: It helps set the makeup.
Nicous: 这个电视你买过的吗
Nicous: Did you buy this TV before?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 欧莱雅大家可以回来吃饭了
Katrina: L'Oreal, everyone can come back and eat now.
Katrina: 哎小狗睡觉
Katrina: Hey, the puppy is sleeping.
Choiszt: 你感觉男生行女生是更注重牌子
Choiszt: Do you think guys or girls care more about brands?
Katrina: 男生送女
Katrina: Guys giving gifts to girls...
Katrina: 生你是说送种类还是品牌
Katrina: Are you talking about types or brands?
Katrina: 化妆品一般化妆品肯定要送牌子的
Katrina: For makeup, it's definitely about brands.
Katrina: 用脸上的东西但是
Katrina: Since it's used on the face, but...
Choiszt: 不是说越贵的越好
Choiszt: It's not always the pricier, the better.
Katrina: 但是那个男生没时间做那么多攻略
Katrina: But guys don’t have time to do so much research.
Katrina: 一般还是买牌子的
Katrina: So they usually buy branded stuff.
Katrina: 会踩雷的几率小一点
Katrina: Less chance of getting it wrong.
Nicous: 比如说上次的那个洗面奶我不知道买什么的
Nicous: Like last time, I didn't know which face wash to buy.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 这一般问姐姐问身边的女生会比较好
Katrina: It's usually better to ask an older sister or a female friend.
Katrina: 你可算问对人了
Katrina: You’re asking the right person.
Katrina: 哈哈我当时大一大二的时候狂买
Katrina: Haha, back in my freshman and sophomore years, I bought a lot.
Katrina: 当时也是刚化妆嘛
Katrina: I just started using makeup then.
Katrina: 就什么都想买
Katrina: Wanted to buy everything.
Katrina: 口红买十几支口红
Katrina: I bought like a dozen lipsticks.
Katrina: YSL的唇釉特别好用
Katrina: YSL lip stains are really good.
Katrina: YSL的唇釉是那种无人能敌
Katrina: YSL lip stains are unbeatable.
Katrina: 610跟440610440416416
Katrina: 610 and 440, 610, 440, 416, 416.
Katrina: 那个也很好看对吧
Katrina: Those are great too, right?
Katrina: 对啊 610
Katrina: Yeah, 610.
Katrina: 绕后
Katrina: Go around the back.
Katrina: 香奈儿有个唇釉也好用
Katrina: Chanel has a lip gloss that's really good.
Katrina: 香奈儿的炫光唇釉
Katrina: The Chanel glossy lip gloss.
Katrina: 嗯就是这种镜面的
Katrina: Yeah, it's like this mirror effect.
Katrina: 然后一般丝绒的
Katrina: And usually the velvet ones.
Katrina: 丝绒的话我感觉国货的就挺好用
Katrina: For velvet ones, I think domestic brands are pretty good too.
Katrina: 哎不如买口红
Katrina: Oh, maybe just buy a lipstick.
Katrina: 但香奈儿有一个
Katrina: But Chanel has one...
Katrina: 那个黑管口红还挺好用
Katrina: That black tube lipstick is quite good.
Katrina: 还有啥牌子
Katrina: What other brands?
Katrina: YSL的那个小黑条也好用
Katrina: YSL's black tube is also good.
Katrina: 我一般买YSL跟香奈儿比较多
Katrina: I usually buy a lot of YSL and Chanel.
Katrina: 关门
Katrina: Close the door.
Katrina: l：我们直接上去吗
Katrina: Are we going straight up?
Katrina: 我这诗句要串码
Katrina: My poem lines are going to mix up.
Jake:嗯你先上去跟大家对齐一下
Jake: Yeah, you go up first and align with everyone.
Katrina: 今天给可可给你采了非常丰富的数据
Katrina: Today, I collected a lot of rich data for Coco.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Katrina: 外景然后包括情感数据
Katrina: Outdoor shots and also emotional data.
Katrina: 情感文本
Katrina: Emotional texts.
Katrina: 今天这位提供的
Katrina: Provided by this one today.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这位
Katrina: This one.
Katrina: 进行一些情感语言分析吧
Katrina: Let's do some emotional language analysis.
Katrina: 还有一些小狗
Katrina: And some puppies.
Jake:你的这是什么
Jake: What is this of yours?
Shure: 回来了
Shure: I'm back.
Jake:三颗钱还是什么
Jake: Three coins or something?
Alice:怎么洗不掉呢奇怪
Alice: Why can't I wash it off, strange.
Katrina: 非常非常丰富
Katrina: Very, very rich.
Jake:三三颗出伪金币吗还是
Jake: Three, three fake gold coins or what?
Katrina: 哈哈哈都有
Katrina: Hahaha, there's everything.
Jake:什么都有
Jake: There's everything.
Jake:很多是吧
Jake: A lot, right?
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Jake:要火要火
Jake: It's going to be popular.
Shure: 没人吧
Shure: No one here, right?
Katrina: 哇团建的感觉
Katrina: Wow, feels like a team building activity.
Jake:一会开吃了再结束吧
Jake: Let's start eating and then finish up.
Jake:就是把这个都拆开
Jake: Just open all of these.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: OK
Shure: 我们来来个同学帮我一下
Shure: Can someone help me out here?
Jake:开吃就
Jake: Let's start eating then
Jake:来要干啥
Jake: What do we need to do?
Shure: 直接倒到那里面
Shure: Just pour it in there directly
Alice:这啥玩意怎么洗不掉呢
Alice: What is this? Why won't it wash off?
Shure: 省得我一点一点接了是吧
Shure: So I don't have to do it bit by bit, right?
Katrina: 诶从哪搞两锅啊
Katrina: Hey, where can we get two pots from?
Jake:哦哦走赶走
Jake: Oh, oh, let's hurry up
Shure: 然后这个拿着吧
Shure: Here, hold this
Katrina: 就有啊哦
Katrina: Got it, alright
Shure: 别别让这个粘着那什么
Shure: Don't let it stick to anything
Jake:哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, okay
Katrina: 我以为要借
Katrina: I thought we had to borrow it
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Alice:然我说这洗不掉
Alice: I said it won't wash off
Jake:你别碰他
Jake: Don't touch it
Alice:这什么玩意
Alice: What is this?
Jake:就这样就行了
Jake: Just leave it as it is
Lucia: 有就是有的菜叶子上它就
Lucia: Sometimes there are leaves like this
Jake:就没必要了
Jake: It's unnecessary
Lucia: 就长这样还是怎么回事
Lucia: It's just how it grows or something
Lucia: 我们家洗菜也是
Lucia: We wash vegetables at home too
Jake:是没必要了
Jake: It's unnecessary
Lucia: 就是有时候这个东西它是洗不掉的
Lucia: Sometimes this stuff just doesn't wash off
Alice:摸摸
Alice: Touch it
Jake:倒个数据呗
Jake: Pour the data
Lucia: 应该它就长这样
Lucia: It should be like this
Alice:好像长上去了一样
Alice: Seems like it grew on it
Jake:数据倒了倒了
Jake: The data is poured
Lucia: 对它就长这样
Lucia: Yeah, it's just like this
Alice:好你给我做个见
Alice: Alright, be my witness
Alice:证啊
Alice: Okay?
Alice:放心吧我确实洗了
Alice: Don't worry, I really washed it
Lucia: 好放心吧
Lucia: Alright, don't worry
Lucia: 他就长这样
Lucia: It just grows like this
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Katrina: 哇哦
Katrina: Wow
Shure: 这放放顶上
Shure: Put it on top
Shure: 不然话我一会钻不过去
Shure: Otherwise, I can't get through later
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 我对我自己几斤几两非常有点逼数
Shure: I know exactly what I'm capable of.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know that, right?
Lucia: 我踩着啥了刚才
Lucia: What did I step on just now?
Shure: 呦呦呦
Shure: Yo yo yo
Lucia: 你小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful.
Lucia: 主要是别碰到接口什么的地方
Lucia: Just make sure you don't touch the connectors or anything.
Katrina:  没事擦一下吧
Katrina: It's okay, just wipe it off.
Lucia: 呃楼上是不是没有抹布好像哎有
Lucia: Uh, do we have a rag upstairs? Oh, we do.
Jake:楼上是不是没有啊
Jake: Is there none upstairs?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Jake:这个声音太少了
Jake: The sound is too low.
Tasha: 这个水明显少了
Tasha: There's clearly not enough water.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 没事我们一会拿那个开水直接补吧
Shure: No problem, we'll just add some boiling water later.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Jake:用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Use Wahaha water.
Katrina: 先拿抹布擦
Katrina: First, wipe it with a rag.
Lucia: 呃
Lucia: Uh
Jake:啊用娃哈哈的水
Jake: Ah, use Wahaha water.
Lucia: 啊娃哈哈的水就是说它的水很健康啊
Lucia: Ah, Wahaha water, it means the water is very healthy.
Tasha: 就是说他的水很健康的感觉
Tasha: It means the water feels very healthy.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: OK实验室用水
Lucia: OK, lab use water.
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有
Jake: Hahaha, no, no.
Jake:我乱说的
Jake: I'm just kidding.
Katrina: 想喝个饮料
Katrina: I want a drink.
Jake:本身我们还有一个环节
Jake: Actually, we have another segment.
Jake:就是给你们五六种这种矿泉水
Jake: We give you five or six kinds of mineral water.
Jake:让你们去分
Jake: And let you distinguish them.
Shure: 啊可以啊
Shure: Ah, sounds good.
Katrina: 这是你设计的某种游戏吗
Katrina: Is this a game you designed?
Lucia: 然后呢谁先把这些水喝完谁是赢家吗
Lucia: And then whoever finishes the water first is the winner?
Jake:谁能分辨得出来
Jake: Whoever can tell the difference.
Shure: 没问题
Shure: No problem.
Shure: 万事俱备
Shure: All set.
Shure: 只他娘的欠东风
Shure: Just missing the final touch.
Shure: 东风是什么呢
Shure: What's the final touch?
Shure: 东风就是火锅底料
Shure: The final touch is the hotpot base.
Jake:为什么
Jake: Why?
Tasha: 火锅底料呢
Tasha: What about the hotpot base?
Tasha: 那个那个所有的料的那个袋子
Tasha: The bag with all the ingredients?
Jake:the这15分钟
Jake: The... these 15 minutes
Katrina: 在楼下
Katrina: It's downstairs.
Tasha: 哦对
Tasha: Oh, right.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Is that so?
Tasha: 是不是还要拿一些
Tasha: Do we need to get some more?
Tasha: 8个碗 8个碟
Tasha: 8 bowls, 8 plates.
Tasha: 嗯碗有
Tasha: Hmm, we have bowls.
Lucia: 呃碗有但盘子不够咱就用小碗吧
Lucia: Uh, we have bowls but not enough plates. Let's just use small bowls.
Tasha: 但盘子不够
Tasha: But not enough plates.
Tasha: 咱就用小碗吧嗯
Tasha: Let's just use small bowls, hmm.
Lucia: 因为他这的盘子都是那种大一点的
Lucia: Because the plates here are all big ones.
Lucia: 而且好像没有8个
Lucia: And it seems like there aren't 8 of them.
Lucia: 至少楼上没有
Lucia: At least not upstairs.
Lucia: 不过小碗已经都拿出来了
Lucia: But I've already taken out the small bowls.
Tasha: 就拿碗吧
Tasha: Let's just use bowls.
Lucia: 对然后那有3个是楼下洗过
Lucia: Yes, and three of them were washed downstairs.
Lucia: 我直接拿上来了
Lucia: I just brought them up directly.
Tasha: 一二三四五五个
Tasha: One, two, three, four, five, five of them.
Lucia: 然后对然后
Lucia: And then, yes, then...
Tasha: 再拿三个碗
Tasha: Get three more bowls.
Lucia: 呃池子里应该还有几个
Lucia: Uh, there should be a few more in the sink.
Lucia: 反正我刚把底下都拿出来了
Lucia: Anyway, I already took everything out from downstairs.
Lucia: 我先去拿一下那个调料
Lucia: I'll go get the seasoning first.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 帮我把菜端过去
Tasha: Help me carry the dishes over.
Lucia: 哎你已经找到了
Lucia: Oh, you already found it?
Shure: 我找到了啊
Shure: I found it, yeah.
Tasha: 吃饭也要开棚
Tasha: Even eating requires setting up a tent.
Jake:iPhone
Jake: iPhone.
Jake:今天比较富裕
Jake: Today we're quite well-off.
Shure: 有有一个
Shure: There is one.
Jake:今天是富裕上
Jake: Today we are well-off.
Shure: 要变成纯清汤
Shure: It will turn into a clear broth.
Shure: 这就一包啊
Shure: This is just one packet, huh.
Katrina: 这就一包啊
Katrina: This is just one packet, huh.
Shure: 对这就一包
Shure: Yes, just one packet.
Jake:梦
Jake: Dream.
Tasha: 一包不能拆成两包用吗
Tasha: Can't we split one pack into two?
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh
Tasha: 他这个是写3-5人吃
Tasha: This says it serves 3-5 people.
Katrina: 他这个你撕一下
Katrina: You can just tear it open.
Shure: 其实也不是不行
Shure: Actually, it's not impossible.
Katrina: 对他应该是一锅的量
Katrina: Right, it's meant for one pot.
Tasha: 怎么办
Tasha: What should we do?
Katrina: 然后就分成两个半
Katrina: Then just split it into two halves.
Tasha: 我也撕开
Tasha: I'll tear it open too.
Shure: 我们我们吃辣的水平是什么样的
Shure: So, how good are we with spicy food?
Shure: 家人们
Shure: Guys?
Katrina: 我很能吃辣
Katrina: I can handle really spicy food.
Shure: OK四个全
Shure: OK, all four pieces then.
Shure: 下一个里
Shure: Into the next one.
Katrina: 哈哈哈总有刁民想害朕
Katrina: Hahaha, some people always want to mess with me.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 辣辣不死你
Shure: It won't kill you, don't worry.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 明天不用拍摄
Shure: No filming tomorrow.
Shure: 大家都在厕所
Shure: Everyone will be in the bathroom.
Tasha: 那那就各分一半吧
Tasha: Then let's just split it in half.
Shure: 哎呦呦
Shure: Oh, come on.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha: 各分一半了
Tasha: Split it in half then.
Shure: 行行行这就各分一半吧
Shure: Alright, alright, let's just split it in half.
Katrina: 强制下班喽case
Katrina: Forced to take a break, case closed.
Tasha: 那这个火锅底料反正是4块
Tasha: So, this hotpot base has four pieces.
Tasha: 不如一个里面下两块
Tasha: How about we put two pieces in one pot?
Shure: 就我一个人下两块
Shure: Just me putting in two pieces?
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Sure.
Shure: 这哪到哪
Shure: How far can it go?
Shure: 撒撒嘴吧就是
Shure: It's just a small taste.
Katrina: 刚从成都回来
Katrina: Just came back from Chengdu.
Tasha: 一个是两
Tasha: One is two.
Tasha: 一个锅是下两块
Tasha: One pot gets two pieces.
Tasha: 一个锅是下半袋
Tasha: One pot gets half a pack.
Lucia: 啊下半袋的意思是
Lucia: Ah, half a pack means...
Lucia: 是这个里面少下一块吗
Lucia: Does it mean we put one less piece in it?
Lucia: 啊OK OK那这个也是拆开放到这里面
Lucia: Ah, OK, OK, so we split it and put it in here.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Alright.
Lucia: 那我就拆了
Lucia: Then I'll open it.
Tasha: 不要让两种味道混合
Tasha: Don't let the two flavors mix.
Shure: i missing you my honey
Shure: I miss you, my honey.
Shure: don t you
Shure: Don't you?
Katrina: （歌词）我是一个被你没犹豫的小丑
Katrina: (singing) I'm a clown, abandoned without hesitation by you.
Shure: tell me
Shure: Tell me.
Lucia: 怎么只有这一锅水最多
Lucia: Why is this the only pot with the most water?
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh no.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 啊这怎么办
Tasha: Ah, what do we do?
Shure: 什么一袋
Shure: What, just one bag?
Katrina: 怎么了
Katrina: What's wrong?
Tasha: 只有一袋
Tasha: There's only one bag.
Shure: 什么一袋不行吧
Shure: What, one bag isn't enough, right?
Tasha: 我的建议是把这个袋子撕开
Tasha: My suggestion is to tear open the bag.
Tasha: 然后倒一半
Tasha: And then pour out half.